welcome everyone uh this is Nathaniel and Nate from Thinking With and we're just recording a
really quick um episode to just uh update you on a few things that have been going on on our end
as you may have noticed we haven't uploaded any new episodes on the Hegel Tapes and that's because
we're done with it it's 12 12 episodes we made it through the uh the the preface and the intro and
the first um uh section or so of the the meat of the text and we're done with it um for a few
reasons you know it's it's a long book and at the pace that we were going you know we didn't want
this to run until what do you think Nate 2025 um yeah yeah it would have kept going for years
probably yeah yeah and we just wanted something a little bit fresh try to keep these these seasons
manageable uh the other thing is is that um over the the course of recording the Hegel Tapes you know
we just had other things that we were interested in and some other people that were interested in
recording with us and um Dr. Caddy Alford uh wanted to jump in and read The Logic of Sense by Gilles
Deleuze um she's writing she for those of you who know her work you know that she is a fantastic
thinker of um of opinion or uh in the Greek doxa and she's currently writing a book manuscript on that
topic and she really wanted to think about the relationship between uh sense and Deleuze and
doxa so she kind of uh was the catalyst for our for for our second season and you'll you'll hear her
um uh on several episodes uh in in a few weeks and she really brings a great energy and perspective
to those episodes so um really we just want to it's just Nate and I here today John is uh he's stuck at
the beach um without any internet I I just don't know how he's gonna make it no Wi-Fi golfing every
day um you know it's good you know thoughts and prayers thoughts and prayers but we um we actually
started recording um this was it late December early January Nate yeah yeah it was right in the at the
end of December that we recorded the first episode on The Logic of Sense with Caddy yeah so we've been
actually doing it for a few months and we're getting close to finishing up our last few sessions and
our goal is to shape that into another about 10 to 12 episode season a major difference is is that we
will get through the whole book and not just the whole book but also um the uh uh essay appendix at the
back of the book um uh "The Simulacrum and Ancient Philosophy" yeah we're actually finishing the book
and it's not like it's uh any less dense than the Phenomenology I think it's just simply shorter
is that the reason why we're finishing it yeah I think so I mean you know John and I have more
familiarity with with Deleuze maybe that was part of the reason that we that we just went a little bit
faster also the the structure of the book is just a little bit different than the lot than um the
Phenomenology in that it's not organized by chapters but it's organized by series and they're short what
between six and ten pages each so you know every week we go through somewhere between one to three of
those those those series right yeah and I think taking up Deleuze here too not only because you guys are uh
basically experts uh in Deleuzian thinking but also because Deleuze is like the perfect foil uh to Hegel he's
he's the anti-dialectical thinker par excellence and self-described anti-Hegelian but I also think he
offers um sort of a unique um take in terms of the relationship between language and materiality or between
subjectivity and uh you know relations so Deleuze is sort of for me because I I take up a critique
basically of post-humanism or of empiricism in my dissertation that I'm working on right now but Deleuze offers a much
much more sophisticated version of what you could call an empiricist mindset so there's no like there's no
gotcha like Zizekian critique that you can level against Deleuze through Hegel um and even even though
Deleuze is again uh a self-described anti-Hegelian thinker um he does offer you know a way of thinking
the threshold between language and matter that can only be described for me as Hegelian so that's kind
of the paradox of of reading Deleuze for me and obviously you you and John take a slightly different
line um but it's been really productive uh you know thinking through those paradigms well I think it's
exactly that paradox that has made this reading so interesting and and you say that John and I are
more or less experts on Deleuze and while we're certainly you know much more inclined toward Deleuze
and and you know Deleuze is one of the major figures in both of our our research one of the fun things
that really happened during our recordings of the Hegel Tapes was that you know really working through
Hegel and you know with the backdrop of that kind of um um opposition or or antagonism between Deleuze and
Hegel eventually started to give way about halfway through that season and I mean I think there's an
episode where John is very explicitly like I think I'm turning a corner on Hegel some you know it's this
very Hegelian moment and um and what's what's that that's done for me at least is sort of trouble that
feeling or position of expertise with Deleuze and you know even just really sort of question simple
things like all right if Deleuze um has a problem with oppositions and that's his problem
with Hegel then what would it possibly mean for him to be anti-Hegelian and you know that's there's not
a simple quick answer to that but i think as you know Nate you were just saying that that paradox that
that the relationship um between Deleuze and Hegel is really really rich really really interesting
and also productively upsets i think a lot of that that sense of expertise because we go through these
series in much the same way as we do go through the Phenomenology of Spirit of spirit we're not
explaining things we're not teaching it we're not sort of like making our thesis claims on the
relationship between Deleuze and rhetorical theory we are reading it and letting it provoke us and you
know we're thinking with it and and each other and that's the the sort of the mainstay of of
both of the whole podcast of both seasons yeah for sure and i mean maybe uh one could argue and
Žižek certainly argues that Deleuze uh basically offers a straw man of Hegel and that could be true but
you know and Hegel does or i mean Deleuze does offer strict sort of logical formal critiques of
Hegel system like i've been writing through this the last couple days but basically we don't want to
get too technical on this like basically intro you're in it deep Nate you're in it i'm already i'm
currently in it too deep to even get out I'm in the weeds it's yeah but uh so like difference or
relationality or becoming whatever words you want to call that kind of ontological uh set of relations
of relations category of relations for Deleuze is primary to and constitutive of opposition or
contradiction right and that's the basic logical or formal um intervention into Hegel system where
opposition is actually logically primary to difference so it's a reversal of the Hegelian
copula um now beyond that uh i think Deleuze's intervention stems primarily from an ethical
concern with the motivations and effects of the dialectic because as we've seen humanist thinking
dialectical thinking you know uh according to Nietzsche Heidegger and of course Deleuze uh has pretty
pretty pretty concerning ethical and political implications when you think about the the divisions
of the humanist subject and how that maps onto the social field and you know identity politics and all of
that so i i i think that um for any serious interlocutor with Hegel as Deleuze is the the concern is
again with the ethical dimensions of the dialectic not exclusively with uh you know any kind of logical
critique of Hegel um but i'm can i'm like i said i'm in the weeds with this right now and i i find it
interesting to write through those problematics and i and i'm i'm want to continue doing that it's it's a
real struggle because Deleuze does not he's not an example of an easy target which for me in my
dissertation someone like Karen Barad does sometimes offer like an easy cleaner target for for for someone
like Hegel Deleuze is not that which which makes for a productive podcast you know yeah uh well i think
you know one of the things that i think we'll be thinking through quite well we do think through
quite a bit in um our engagement with this book just really is the the logic and functioning of the
the paradox and the opposition and what's fun coming to this book out of Hegel is that for both thinkers
opposition is not non-exclusive right that uh oppositional relation it oppositional relations is in some
ways an engine of the dialectic you know the the self-negation of of the subject which doesn't
annihilate or obliterate but is actually the engine for change and oppositions and paradoxes are also
going to play a pretty vital role in the movement of thinking and Deleuze and then yet right
you know i'm going to channel a little bit of john here and say and yet the style of how those oppositions
operate is very different i think you hit it on the head and said and saying that a lot of that
difference sort of operates at an ethical level or at least calls into question a lot of ethical
uh ramification a lot of ethical ramifications sort of get called up and then right right i would just
be curious you know just to try to turn to the the book a little bit just to kind of give a big picture
gloss of what we're going to be talking about i mean this thing is trippy right yeah i mean we start off
with a reading of Alice in Wonderland and Lewis Carroll and um you know Deleuze touches on
everything from Humpty Dumpty to Through the Looking-Glass and then suddenly you're reading about
the ancient Stoics and their metaphysics and and um ethics and then you know you're thinking about the
theater of cruelty i mean just in terms of the the topical array the topography of this thing it's
it's pretty wild, right? Right. And it invites the reader in a much different way, um, than does Hegel's
text, which is laid out, um, even though the dialectic is not linear, the book kind of presents itself in
this narrative fashion where it's the progression of subjectivity or spirit to its culmination in absolute
spirit, and Deleuze's writing never engages that kind of explicit linear or teleological narrative.
Right. We we talk stylistically it's it's series rather than chapters, which just by that very fact
upsets, um, that kind of narrative or linear logic and invites the reader to kind of sample just like
the uh what's the what's the other uh book the fucking oh oh uh A Thousand Plateaus
A Thousand Plateaus, um, right, has are they called series in that one? No, those are plat, they're plateaus.
Jesus Christ, really messing up this part of the intro. But yeah, um, yeah. But so like with A Thousand
Plateaus, right, um, you're Deleuze invites the reader to sit on a various plateau and allow that kind of
engagement to do you know basically whatever you want it to do. For Hegel it's much more, um, authoritarian,
right? Like this is how I framed it, this is how I want you to read it from back to or for front to
back, you know? Yeah. You start with the first sentence of that preface in the Phenomenology of Spirit and
you are locked in and you have to go to the next, the third, the fourth, the fifth, the sixth, and if you
accidentally skip from the sixth to the eighth you might be like, despite the fact you know how many
times do we note that you know Hegel is an incredibly, um, retro, um, um, yeah, reflective thinker who's like I was
wrong three pages earlier and then I was wrong two pages earlier and but to figure out the particular
ways in which he was wrong you have to follow through it really really meticulously, um, and you
know the I also totally agree what you say about Deleuze's A Thousand Plateaus is that you know Deleuze and
Guattari are very explicit in saying, you know, there is not a linear structure to this book. You can
read any plateau independent of any other plateau. You can read the plateaus in any order and then
depending on the order and the length and the intensity the book changes, you know, constantly, and
that was kind of the an approach that we were taking to The Logic of Sense but we also, I mean, a number of
episodes we're like wow there there is a little bit more of this sort of linear structure and calling
back to previous series and so that's one of the fun things that i that was fun for me to sort of try
to get a handle on this composition which is not it's it's not simply you know a linear chapter by
chapter progression but it's also not quite you know the rhizomatic structure that is A Thousand Plateaus.
Right, and and I kind of find like it doesn't really matter how you read a text. I mean like we read Deleuze
almost more like you would be encouraged to read Hegel like we read the series in order like so we didn't
exactly follow um Deleuze's advice in the preface to A Thousand Plateaus but it still led to like you
were saying that kind of retrospective reading where each series informed the other and kind of folded
back onto one another and I found that reading uh that style of reading similar um with the
Phenomenology, like the more you get into the weeds with the system the more the reading folds back
onto the previous sections and then you can when you go back obviously you're going to have a diff there's
a different light uh and different kind of uh refractive uh reading uh on those on those
previous sections which is highly productive especially when you're like I am in the writing
mode and trying to actually get some good chunks, some good concepts for use, some good portions for for
commentary out of these texts which is how i tend to read stuff anyway like i mean obviously in grad school
which is what i'm still in in the tail end encourages you at some level like for comprehensive
reading where you're encouraged to read everything so like everything that comes at you
you have to read it all and the the implicit assumptions that you're supposed to understand it all
and I've always found that a kind of sampling approach which basically is what Deleuze encourages
is more productive right? I mean not only because I'm lazy but but because you always have to have for me
you always have to have writing in mind when you're reading: like how am I going to use or employ this stuff
uh for my project and how is it going to shape my project, you know? Yeah, I mean I so distinctly
remember those periods of grad school where especially, you know, preparing for the comprehensive exam and doing
the preliminary stuff on the dissertation or frankly all through the the dissertations you just feel this
demand to develop some kind of stable understanding of this huge corpus, this huge body of of work, and
be like oh I could now see you know why how where and how and why you know Hegel's responding to Kant or
you know whatever else it might be and I just never was able to do that and I remember a time that was
you know existentially terrifying from like do i belong here you know this is for sure you know i don't
i haven't you know nailed every every peg into the into the board and as that anxiety
waned i was just increasingly a matter of reading broadly you know sometimes you really
dive deep and latch on to something and really develop something so much of it is just sort of like
developing a sense and orientation it really is in that platonic sense sort of a a process of
orienting your soul toward uh toward a discourse toward a a constellation of concepts and problems and
yeah right right i mean yeah you kind of just have to focus yourself i feel like a lot of people
especially early in grad school or maybe early in their uh professional writing careers they feel
that pressure to know everything which ironically makes it harder to know anything because you're
kind of spreading yourself thin i mean the cliche is right like work smart not hard and i mean basically
what that means in this context is find what you can key into and really work hard at that so you're
still right you still have to work hard but you have to know how your sensibility molds to a particular
discourse and if you can lock in uh you know and and i and i think that's that's underrated or it's
not something that's really talked about all that much um well even that can be super anxiety
inducing because even if you're like all right find your niche and know it yeah well guess what that
niche is attached to literally everything else so you know if i'm like all right i'm at this nexus
and i know these streets but i only know small parts of them and then you're like fuck well if i
am going to comment on you know like gender performativity then obviously i need to be
you know completely grounded in the i don't know the cogito or something or whatever else it might be
because it's like six degrees of philosophical separation you start somewhere you're going to
get to everything you're right you're right don't try to give me more anxiety than i already have about
my no i'm trying i'm trying to relax and try to relax it you know even don't even think that you have to
know concretely your your niche right yeah no that's true you're right you're right just you
just gotta start basically you gotta start writing man and it's it's been fun because i've been in
Columbia for six days and i don't want to brag and this is going to sound boastful how many pages give
me the number 24 hot damn 24 new pages of now some of it a little bit of it has been like sampled like
like like we've been talking about from like uh just notes but most of it is new
shit and so i i'm just pumped i'm nearly ecstatic about my uh ability to write because i wasn't sure
i haven't been in the that zone for a while like for more than a year basically at where i've written
like that kind of clip um for the for the prospectus so it's like it's just been really nice to get back
into that rhythm John and I were just talking about this because we we were chatting following up on
comments he had on something that i had written and we're just talking about in general the difficulty
of writing and part of you know his insight was it just writing can so often feel claustrophobic and
monologic and you know it's just like you're expressing the thing that's already there which is just
for him for me i assume for you and for a lot of people just boring and and you know the the insight
was that in some ways you have to invite a certain kind of schizophrenia to allow some kind of like
internal internal dialogue some kind of internal conversation to get those those um that writing
out and i know you know all too well that my worst bouts of writing are when i think that i know i
need what i need to say and then i just need to sort of churn it out versus when i feel like i've been
invaded by whatever it is i'm reading or thinking about right and it's it's it's almost like the reading is
forcing you to make new kinds of arguments that you weren't even prepared maybe even willing to make
where it's actually like challenging your brain to accommodate you know the complexity or ambiguity
of the text how great are those moments where you you write yourself in some trajectory and you're like
wait how did i get here right right and it and it feels natural and it sounds natural in the writing
sometimes because of it's the movement of thinking and that's what you want you know like as Hegel and
and Deleuze show us you want to kind of track the movement of thinking in some ways in the writing
and we and we talk a lot about the the writing process in these podcasts and the teaching and
reading processes and i i think that's also what makes um the episodes fairly relatable and listenable
because even if you are not uh you know familiar with some of the the theoretical terminology um that
might be kind of uh it might be too foreign for for certain listeners but a lot of our uh conversations
not really diverge but just we'll we'll talk through not only the text but um the reading and
writing processes and what makes them tick like we like we've just kind of uh outlined it they definitely
just they they interweave that's what i like about it is you know we're not talking Hegel or Deleuze we're
talking how Hegel and Deleuze and these sections intertwine with each other with writing and teaching
practices with contemporary political events or orientations and you know they just kind of create
their own little singularity so i think you're right you know you don't you know for our listeners that are
not uh philosophically uh uh disciplined and and sort of you know a lot of the terminology goes
over the head that doesn't mean you can't track the conversation because i i think a lot of our
conversations they just don't rely on that right to give you a different perspective on what we're saying
but yeah and you might find even if you're not uh sort of trained in that language you might find
yourself getting into a rhythm with it i mean i i get that it's it's sometimes weird and foreign
and difficult but i i constantly come back to the analogy if it's just like it's basically like
learning German or something you know so you're not going to know it right away but the more you listen
to it you're gonna you're gonna pick up on things you know not sure you're gonna pick up on patterns and
structures right so and i i do find myself wanting to write more at least occasionally in like common or
like lay person's terminology because i've gotten kind of so far into this weird technical like alien
discourse that sometimes it's hard to like bring yourself out of that and write a simple sentence
that everybody could understand oh god i remember that so well i i remember just like a couple of
years probably straight where i felt like i couldn't write a short declarative sentence it was
i mean it was like i had a disease and i had to battle it and one of the things that that really helped
that actually is i i generally don't lecture in my classes and i don't write lectures for a long time
i didn't but in a couple of my classes you know sort of during our debrief time as i sort of have been
expanding the scope of things that i'm that i'm teaching um you know the feedback that i got was
like hey you know we love the class conversation it's great um but this a lot of this stuff is really
foreign for us we'd love just a little bit like we'd love a bit of the class to be you know your overview
of the thing and your take on the thing and then we can you know still have most of the time for class
and so you know i've sort of taken that approach where now maybe like 25 percent of our class minutes
in a given week will be my lectures since you know i'm writing a couple of lectures a week
and writing to an audience who has read the stuff and has some inclination but is definitely not going
to be helpful to write in that hyper-technical way and so having the the the audience the imagined
audience of my students that has been really helpful for me for jarring me out of that of that space
right i mean i like again like i like reading that kind of the technical terminology and you're not
going to find i mean you're going to find simply constructed sentences in Hegel but because of the
terminology it's going to be incomprehensible for any person who just picks up the text i enjoy reading
that kind of stuff but i understand that for for most people even in our discipline like if that's
the only register in which you're writing like it's it's not going to be accessible yeah i love reading
it and writing it too it's just there's always that learning curve where you're falling off the bike
for the first you know x number goes of goes at it right and then suddenly it clicks and we're like oh
yeah you know this thing that was like almost borderline unreadable for me before now i you
know more or less right blast through it yeah and i've been trying to like um come up with more
concrete examples to that that will kind of be in that lay register and i'm really bad right now at
writing them and they they they come they come across as like juvenile usually and it's almost like
it's like i've been writing all this technical uh conceptual stuff and then i try to i try to relay
an example and all of a sudden i sound like a third grader like trying to like it just it just
collapses and falls apart now last night at 3 a.m. i came up with an example uh of of like the the
the workings or movement of the dialectic through uh Dragon Ball Z which is a a classic anime and i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna run through the example right now um but it was like an epiphany where i was like
oh this is sort of this is what an example should sound like and i haven't been able to do that until
that moment yeah last night giving examples so well i've got to get at least one uh night owl joke in
here so 3 a.m. that was your lunch break yeah yeah i was just uh i was just actually waking up eating
breakfast, uh, or no, no, that wouldn't make any sense. That would be the Mark Mark Wahlberg schedule, I think.
He literally wakes up at 4 a.m. and like works out for seven hours straight. I'm the opposite. I go to bed
at 4 a.m., wake up at noon, and then start my day. There you go. Um, I, yeah, the number of times, you know, I've
done like those really cliched philosopher examples of like the pen or the table or if I want to get
really edgy, the beer or something like that. Yeah, oh my God, it's like the equivalent of the freshman
saying, you know, since the beginning of time, right? I know, I don't know why that it always comes, it, it
sounds again so juvenile to me when I try to write in that mode, um, because your head's totally fixated
on one thing. You're not thinking about, you know, relatable examples. You're already down that rabbit
hole and then you've got to find an example, so you literally look on your desk, right? Exactly, or I, you
know, I've been watching a ton of basketball so I tried to do a basketball example and it just
and it fell totally flat and I just deleted it, but I, I do want to and I'm going to, I, I will
I promise you I will write not only well maybe about Melo but more about Damian Lillard. I mean
because first of all because we'll be releasing this episode this week or whatever we can talk about
this, but that was the single most amazing playoff performance I've ever seen. Damian's ability
to make pressure cooker shots is insane. It's, I was watching it live and I could not believe
what he was doing on the court and of course they lost, which I was so disappointed, but the the fact
that Damian is his ability to do that, I'm going to relate that to Hegel and it will make sense.
His his unconscious ability to make three pointers. No one self-negates like Damian Lillard. Exactly, he
negates everything, all otherness in the pursuit of the whip. But yeah, talk about a guy that can get
into the zone whenever he whenever he wants, at least in the mean playoffs, it feels like. Yeah, well, you know
what I was thinking too though is that it almost seems like he needs to be down points: like there's
something in his brain or in his bodily, you know, uh, complex where if they're down he will not miss. If
they're tied or if they're up a point now maybe this is just from the last game he will start missing or
start passing the ball, but when they're down a few points get him the ball, he's not going to miss, he's
just not going to miss the shot. Yeah, is that maybe there's less pressure when you're down?
Maybe, maybe, uh, that would be, but I don't want to, I don't want to get dude Dame like that.
I want him to win, dude. I want him to actually win. They lost that game, he scored 55, set the record for
three pointers in a playoff game and his team sucks so fucking bad that they still lost. They couldn't
get I, I didn't get to watch it because it happens at 3 a.m. whatever it was, but um, I was checking out
the stats this morning and you know it's not just that Dame had an insane scoring. I hit a 10 assists
and he shot something like 17 for 22, like some insane percentage. Totally. And then everyone else shot
poorly except for Covington, dude. It was it was so frustrating. He scored 17 points in a row in
overtime and then when he passed the ball for an easy layup to to it was either Covington
and then McCollum they both made these like blatant mistakes, like like it looked like they folded
under the pressure and it was just like how can you do that to a guy that just
wields your team into two separate overtimes?
Well, that's that. Everyone just a bit of a update transition preview of the upcoming season. We love
doing the Hegel tapes and we are really excited to start releasing our first episodes of the new
season which we'll be calling Deluze Cast on Gilles Deleuze's The Logic of Sense and
keep a look at that. That'll be coming out in about a week, maybe two, on uh, on the first day of the week
you